so are you
recording lauren
okay i think i see you are
okay well i would like to welcome
everyone to the biomedical informatics
graduate program
annual open house obviously this year
in a virtual format
which is actually disappointing for us
because we enjoy
getting to meet people we usually do
uh this event on a saturday we serve
pizza
um and have time to talk
so excuse me
um but obviously this year we're in the
midst of a pandemic so we'll need to do
it
this way
so this is the schedule for the open
house including some of you
i know participated in the poster
sessions
that we usually present in our
gallery and the down on the first floor
of our building
so i'll speak for about a half hour
giving an overview
of the entire program we'll then
have breakouts to
cover in more detail the two specific
majors in the program health and
clinical informatics and bioinformatics
and computational biomedicine
there will then be some presentations by
other groups
we'll all come back together for those
the alliance for visible diversity and
science the ohsu center for diversity
and conclusion
inclusion and career services
we'll then have a panel with our
students that will break out again
and you can ask questions of them and
then we'll also
be around to answer any questions and i
certainly will be happy to
answer any questions that anyone has
about our program or the field after the
session today you should have my email
so let me um begin by kind of giving a
big
um the big overview of the programming
field this will not be a repeat
of the lecture i just gave um in our
research conference i will focus
more on the field of informatics
and our educational program
so um maybe it might have been good to
do this
uh talk before the previous one because
some of you may not know
exactly what is biomedical informatics
our view is that it's the field
concerned with the optimal use of
information or maybe these days we
should say data and information
often aided by technology to improve
individual health
healthcare public health and biomedical
research
i maintain a website that provides a
more detailed introduction for the field
which you can click click on here or
just remember it's informatics.health
the field is really more about the data
and information and what we do with it
than the technology itself obviously you
need the technology
to do things with the data and
information but how do we take this data
and information
and improve people's health or improve
the delivery of health care
some have noted that informatics is this
venn diagram that includes people
information and technology
so technology is part of it but
information is
critically important as are the people
because the goal
is to do beneficial things for people
so there are many important roles for
biomedical informatics in 2020
and beyond we have seen over the last 10
years
the widespread adoption of the
electronic health record
and its potential to improve quality and
safety in health care
we've seen an explosion in data science
machine learning artificial intelligence
to maintain health as well as improve
diagnosis and treatment of disease
we have seen the growth of so-called
precision medicine
which brings some of the omics genomics
proteomics
the microbiome other
molecular entities to improving health
and health care
we see the growth of the personal health
record so the
patient's view into their electronic
health record
their use of wearables and other ways
that we engage them in their health
and health care and of course all of
these tools
are critical in the response to the
covet 19 pandemic
there are many career opportunities one
of my research interests has actually
been trying to define
the profession of informatics how many
people work in it
and um we we don't have a real good
handle on it because it's a very diverse
field people work in different settings
people do different kinds of work
and there's no federal
standard occupational classification for
informatics we were hoping there would
be but they chose not to add one in the
most recent update
maybe they will in the future but the
the there's been a substantial growth
and
anywhere um and this growth is estimated
to continue anywhere from nineteen
thousand to a hundred and fifty
000 jobs on top of the 160 000 that
already exists
it's a paper i published a couple years
ago
in terms of numbers the largest
opportunity is in health care settings
but there's plenty of other
opportunities for those who
don't want to work in health care
settings in
research settings research institutes
academic
centers industry many of our graduates
go work
in industry and in
government this was a report
published in 2018 by
the um i have to remember
it's some entity connected with the
united nations i
apologize um
they looked at um the workforce in 2018
and 2022
and which areas were emerging and
declining
and if you look in the emerging areas
you see things that are related to
biomedical informatics
data analysts and scientists biologists
and geneticists ai and machine learning
informational technology information
technology environment
big data um specialist medical
practitioners to some sense
and the things that are declining like
data entry clerks
um automate a factory workers
um things like that so
there are growth opportunities
in um biomedical informatics
in terms of careers this is a busy slide
and um but i just want to kind of show
one of the challenges we have in
biomedical informatics
is the different areas within
informatics
so you may hear the term bioinformatics
i'm looking in the middle part of the
slide
that is informatics that's mostly
focused on cellular molecular
levels moving to the person
medical or clinical informatics or to
the population public health informatics
and people sometimes combine combined
clinical and public health informatics
into health informatics
even within medical or clinical
informatics we don't use the term
medical informatics much anymore you
still see people use it
it's in the name of our department but
there are subfields
different clinical fields radiology
informatics pathology informatics and
also consumer health informatics
and again information at the bottom of
the slide
is this confluence of people information
and technology
there are some other areas outside of
biomedicine and health that use the word
informatics
but it's most prominently used in in
biomedicine and health
and then there's these overarching areas
imaging informatics
that obviously focuses on on imaging and
issues related there
and research informatics all of the
research processes
and informatics related to it
so we are um at ohsu
in the department of medical informatics
and clinical epidemiology
or d mice is our acronym we're one of 26
departments in the ohsu school of
medicine
other departments like the department of
family medicine the department of
radiology the
department of molecular and medical
genetics
um the department of um physiology and
pharmacology
all of the departments are headed by
department chairs of which i'm the chair
of d mice and
we answer to the dean of the school of
medicine dr sharon anderson she's my
boss
our our mission is again leadership
discovery and dissemination of knowledge
in our respective disciplines the um
leadership of the department i actually
did mention them in the last
hour myself as as chair and then
four vice chairs dr mcqueeny dr door dr
eden dr
morris who focus on specific areas
and and dr mcqueen actually oversees the
there's actually a division within the
department of bio
informatics and computational biology
there are no u.s news and world report
rankings
for biomedical informatics maybe someday
there will be
but by any measure we are clearly one of
the leading programs in the country
we're one of 16 that has funding
from the national library medicine nih
training grant
for phd and postdoc students we were one
of nine programs funded
from the office of the national
coordinator health i.t workforce
development program
we were one of eight programs funded
another nih initiative on international
training global health funded by the
fogerty center with colleagues from
argentina we've been a consistent
recipient of research
funding our faculty are appointed to
national leadership
positions they pub publish in high
profile journals
and we have a highly accomplished alumni
that i'll talk a little bit more about
in a moment
um we likewise in d mice the ce part of
it stands for clinical epidemiology
and they are comparably successful
in areas like evidence-based medicine
systematic reviews and and meta-analysis
but we'll focus today on informatics
because the um open house is a
on the graduate program in informatics
so let's talk about the biomedical
informatics graduate program our overall
goal
is to train future professionals
researchers and leaders
in the overall field there's two
different majors they focus on different
areas
of the larger field and all of our
programs are at the graduate level
in other words require a baccalaureate
degree
we have a very um diverse student body
that fall into um well you can probably
slice and dice them in many ways but
we do have a number of um students who
we sometimes call first career students
those who are
younger maybe even just out of college
tending to be full-time and on campus
coming from a variety of backgrounds
but we also have um career changing
students so
individuals who maybe
most commonly are healthcare
professionals but they may come from
other fields
computer science library science etc
and wish to move their career more into
informatics
they're more likely to be part-time
because they already have jobs
oftentimes families too
they're more likely to take advantage of
our online
courses and again mostly but not
exclusively from the health
professions so we have two majors
the first is health and clinical
informatics or hcin
this is actually the original track of
the program we used to call them tracks
and it tends to focus on informatics and
applied
data analytics in health and healthcare
and public health and related areas
the bioinformatics and computational
biomedicine or bcb
major um more
deeply on methods and deep analytics
originally used to focus mostly on omics
but over the years has expanded to other
data sources and
including wending its way into clinical
medicine and public health
so it um there's definitely overlap
between the majors and in fact
students can take courses
things like electives from the other
major
if they're so interested
i mentioned that we have a
large and robust faculty i direct the
program
i also oversee the hcin major
dr shannon mcqueeny um oversees the
uh bcb program and uh
was unable to make it today and is being
represented by dr ted ladaris
um and then dr karen eden oversees
the phd program the phd
students are they're they're
tracked more closely as they go through
their their course of studies
through their dissertation and so forth
and dr eden plays a major role there
and there's over 30 other faculty who
teach
courses advise students mentor them on
projects
mentor them on career development and so
forth
um i showed some of this slide in the
last talk but
again our students come from all over
the country
um and our online students take our
courses from all over the country
um we've awarded um 872 degrees and
certificates to 782 people
who work in a variety of settings and we
have
plenty of international collaboration
another point about our program
is despite its being relatively old for
the informatics field
almost 25 years we continually
improve and update our teaching we
for example in recent years with the
growth of data science we have
incorporated data science
into the curriculum
in a variety of ways
so again we're a graduate program so we
offer phd and master's degrees
phd graduates typically pursue research
or academic careers
or sometimes leadership careers
we actually have two varieties of
master's degree master of science um
a thesis masters that is more of the
traditional
research masters often times by those
who want to go into research careers
including people who have doctoral
degrees in other fields
and then want to incorporate informatics
in their research so we'll get a
master's degree and do a master's thesis
or the non-thesis master is the
that is part of the growing number of
professional masters degrees
who of individuals who seek education
beyond the baccalaureate degree more
specialized education
to work in areas like informatics many
of these graduates become practitioners
we also
for the hcin major have our graduate
certificate
which is a subset of the master's
program
and gives students the ability to
to have a more focused area of study
within
informatics
now we used to say that some of our
programs are on campus some of our
programs are online
in particular in the hcin major the
non-thesis
master of science and graduate
certificate are formally
online programs although in that major
students in the masters with thesis and
phd program
end up taking some of the online courses
just to
um just so the numbers are sufficient
but of course due to covet 19
everything is online now and
the bcb program has done a tremendous
job
i'm sure dr ladaris can tell you more of
moving to online although i suspect they
don't hope to well we'll hopefully
continue aspects of online teaching but
but return
more to classrooms and more direct
personal interaction as we
hope to be able to do in the hcin major
as well
when the pandemic ends um
so for right now everything is online
um our curriculum i i don't have um
well the the breakout sessions will go
into the curriculum in more details but
but basically
in each major um there are domains
which have courses and there are some of
the courses are required
some are what we call individual
competency where you choose from a list
and others are purely elective and
the core of the masters of the master of
science program
in each major is the knowledge base
those who do a masters of science with
thesis
add a thesis those who do master of
science non-thesis
add a smaller capstone project which
actually can also be an internship
and there's rules about how long it
needs to be and
and how much time needs to be spent and
then the phd
which is that same knowledge base so
masters and phd students will
often be in courses together but then
additional advanced research
mostly around research methods and then
of course
completing a dissertation where a
research project is done that
explores a new scientific area of the
field
another way to look at this is is the
building block
model because again the
since the knowledge base of the master's
program is the core of the curriculum
and the graduate certificate for hcin is
a subset of that
the phd is a superset of that that adds
advanced research methods statistics
we also because we think that all of our
phd students will eventually be teaching
we add a mentor
teaching requirement and then of course
the dissertation
you see here something called 10 by 10
down in the bottom left
that that's actually the introductory
course from hcin
which is available as a standalone
course called 10 by 10
although some people take that course
and decide they want to do more
and we have a way to um facilitate
that if they um complete the final exam
for the course they can get credit
for the bmi 510 course that's part of
our curriculum
so we have a highly varied
um input of
students from different backgrounds
health professions
life sciences computer science and
related technology disciplines health
information management even other
majors business majors and so forth they
all
they come in those yellow arrows then
they all get mixed in
with the red in our graduate program
and then they go out and take different
kinds of jobs and oftentimes what you do
when you get out
is partially dependent on what you do
did when you entered a classic example
of this
is the position of chief medical
information officer
which many hospitals have one or
sometimes more than one
um that's typically a physician or
someone who's
trained in healthcare practice
other people who may take more technical
jobs
come in with more technical backgrounds
like computer science or
other i.t related areas
in the end though so there's no single
career pathway or ladder
but in the end people find jobs in
healthcare systems in research settings
in industry and academia
a few other programs of note we also
offer what we call
fellowship programs these are
funded programs so people who are
fellows get a stipend
and their tuition covered and it's
mostly funded through our national
library medicine training grant
though also for physicians in who are
pursuing
the physician subspecialty of clinical
informatics
we have a second fellowship program that
they can enter
and i've mentioned 10 by 10 already
which is a continuing education course
we offer in
partnership with the american medical
informatics association
and about 10 to 15
of those students go on who complete 10
by 10
go on to graduate study and nearly 2 700
have completed that course since 2005.
so we think our program provides
value we are cognizant that
higher education is expensive we
strive to keep our tuition and fees
comparable to other programs
and then we like to add value on top of
that so our cutting edge curriculum
that's based on a solid foundation our
faculty who are international leaders
in research and practice um in
informatics is not
just limited to the classroom our
students
are able to take part in internship or
practicum experiences
we provide you'll meet um virginia
lanke's our
career development specialists
who carries out career development and
advising
and we have a lot of connections to
industry even though we are
up on the hill we don't really view
ourselves up on the hill in the ivory
tower
we try to get to know people in industry
what what are the
skills that you're looking for
um that people should have in order to
successfully work for your company
or health care setting so
i um um
oh i just um we we we have a large
online presence um these
um the research conferences the one some
of you may have heard earlier today are
posted on our youtube channel
and we'll get you these slides or at
least a pdf of them so you can click
through to these links
we do have a web site for the department
this is a vanity url that's just a
little shorter to type than the full
url we have a blog where we
blog about various happenings in the
department
we are active on social media
we have a twitter account we have a
linkedin group
we have a facebook group and we
encourage you
to connect with us through
social media
and again here is um my
contact information and your feel feel
free to reach out to me
i'm gonna stop sharing my screen
and come back here i don't know if there
are any
[Music]
questions